and congratulations i know you just got  engaged we did yeah josh and i got  engaged it was actually so i i have to  say we got engaged like two years ago  speaking with the today show cal opens  up about his 11-year relationship with  josh while also giving us more insight  into their relationship in his book that  drops tomorrow cal also discussed his  personal life with people magazine  saying quote i discovered my own  sexuality relatively late in life  compared to many other people there's no  timeline on this stuff people figure  their blank out at different times in  their lives so i'm glad i did when i did  as for the wedding planning that's next  on cal's list telling people the big  disagreement now is whether it's a huge  wedding or a tiny wedding i want the big  indian wedding josh hates attention has  said or we could just do quick 20 minute  thing with our families and that's it so  we have to meet halfway in the middle